yawn Kobus is an architect so he knows
how to build a regular house but that
does not interest him right now this is
a green silo
it's mine and I want to live in it the
self-styled garbage architect started
work on this project in 2012 his aim was
to build a new home out of things other
people threw away I am so looking
forward to building a house with all the
stuff I have collected the challenge is
to make it as small and nice as possible
so how do you create a two-story home
with kitchen and bathroom with just 13
square meters of living space the silo
stands beside his workshop in The Hague
in the Netherlands fellow architect and
I helped him plenty of experimentation
and brainstorming were needed and a
whole lot of imagination
it was spiral staircase perhaps maybe
not usually you draw up plans then you
get to work but not this time
it is actually harder to build with old
materials and found objects than with
new components the workshop houses quite
a collection of stuff not all of it will
be used this will be a window in the
silo tower home this noble quality is
actually a balcony door but it is much
too small for most people so this model
just didn't sell well fitting square
pegs into round holes and vice versa is
tricky yawn and den I built a frame for
the new balcony door window
the silo is made of fiberglass and
believed to contain toxic substances
still Kobus chose to use it rather than
throw the silo away construction
involved almost no emissions which is
good for the environment and the climate
Yann and his friends and helpers worked
and worked two months in this is what it
looked like
after nine months it was all done
yawn crevice and his daughter Lucia
could finally move in
the silo was topped off with a glass
roof the front steps come from old
scaffolding of course yon did not go out
and buy a new coat rack it's from an old
rake
Yertle our speed counters from an old
stand in trade fair it's aluminum this
is the kitchen
since these are gold heart mints from
the door of a refrigerator where you
keep your milk this is the toilet with
two parts for liquid and solid waste
which is composted pork is the bedroom I
sleep so well here and all the drawers
are customized to fit the shape of the
silo Thimphu enter the bedroom window
you can look out at the Harbor it's
incredible there are many houses with a
view like this there's even enough room
to entertain the legs of Jonker buses
homemade table fit into the corners of
the bathtub saving space
the months and months of hard work paid
off yon Corvis now has a cheap and
cheerful cozy and very unusual home and
now he is keen to work on more silo
conversions